Wilson breaking news this morning from  the West Midlands police and they said  that a 23 year old man has died after  being stabbed on the dance floor of a  nightclub in Birmingham on Boxing Day a  statement from the police gives some  more detail it says we've launched a  murder investigation after a man was  stabbed to death on the dance floor of a  Birmingham nightclub we were called to  the crane nightclub on Adderley Street  in digbeth just before 11 45 PM  yesterday that was the 26th of December  Boxing Day to reports that the 23 year  old had been stabbed despite efforts to  save him he was pronounced dead about 30  minutes later we believe that the victim  was approached by a group of people and  was then stabbed so we're working hard  to identify all of those involved that's  a statement from detective inspector  Michelle Thurgood who is leading that  investigation